- It's not Mexico, but I heard that
you went on a trip, as
well, with your girlfriend
and it was the Cabbage Patch doll museum.
- [Brian] Oh!
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, that's outside Atlanta.
- [Kelly] So I have to ask,
- [Brian] Yeah, that's great.
- You're a fan?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I mean, a fan?
- I'm a fan? Yes.
- [Kelly] Look at that! Now that's-
- [Brian] Yeah, that's cool. That's cool.
- [Kelly] And the nurse there,
the nurses take care of them, right?
- [Cole] I,
- [Lana] What?
- [Cole] This is imagicillin,
please come back for another shot.
- (laughing) What is wrong with us?
- There's something very
macabre about the whole thing.
I, I don't,
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] I didn't even know this existed.
- I, I think they're
going for kind of scary.
It's all, it's all older
women who work there
and they're all dressed as nurses,
and it's, and they all
take it super seriously.
- [Brian] In 2022?
- [Cole] In 2022.
And they all have drank the punch.
They will not break character.
And they, they act like they're delivering
these cabbage patch
babies out of the ground.
- And the whole audience is going now.
We're gonna send them all to-
(Lana laughs)
- [Kelly] And you're...
- [Cole] I'm not getting paid
by Cabbage Patch, by the way.
(audience laughs)
I'm, I'm simply saying
it's a very scary event
but a wonderful date.
- It, no, that's the question, Cole,
(Brian laughing)
is where did the idea come from?
Were you just like,
"I have this great
adventure for our date"?
- [Cole] I was having a
great time in Atlanta,
as you know, everything
shoots down in Atlanta now.
- [Kelly] Now.
- Yeah. In, in the industry.
And I was trying to figure out
something to do on my weekend
that, uh, didn't involve any
sort of physical activity.
- [Kelly] So that's like where you were,
you never visited...
(Lana laughing)
- Well, look, I just found out
that there's a trap museum in Atlanta
that is literally dedicated
to the history of trap music.
- [Cole] That's awesome.
- And I was like, I am not
going to that. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- (laughing) I am not going to that.
- [Brian] Like, they
have, like, they have,
like, Nicki Minaj just
throwing from Beez in the Trap.
They even show you how to actually,
like, cook crack in there.
Not for real! (audience laughs)
but, like, you go through,
it's a history of,
- It's just like the Cabbage Patch...
- It's just like the Cabbage Patch!
- What are these places that exist?
- Only in Atlanta, Kelly!